[Applaudissements]
une guitare et je me
dévine une guitare et plus d'usine j'en
ai marre Mar
Mar je suis pas plus idiot qu'un autre
j'apprendrai à jouer les notes il y a
des gars qui croient en
moi
déjà dis
Mariette tu te rends compes
dis Mariette tu es pas contre
moi dis
Mariette les
paillettes Mariette je serais terrible
Mariette
l'artistique c'est un peu comme le reste
tout c'est d'avoir du culot surtout
unon mon patron un homme gentil m'a dit
que si ça ne collait pas pour moi il me
reprendrait chez
lui
j'avais
pas les
qualités pour faire un bonne un bon
ouvrier il y en a marre
marre
mal et lorsque mon père verra
son nom écrit grand comme ça il sera
sûrement fier de
moi pour une
fois dis Mariette tu te rends
compes dis Mariette tu es pas contre
moi dis
Mariette les
paillettes dis mari
je serai terrible
Mariette tu
verras on aura la belle vie et moi je
serai ton Johnny et toi tu seras ma C
vie sur la scène j'aurai ma formation à
moi Harry Bobi Raymond et toi Mariette
au
balcon
regarde
Mar ser Terri
Mar ser terrible
[Musique]
Mar je ser Terri
mar
[Applaudissements]